bonsoir bienvenue dans savouregarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
l'écrivain Marc Lambron de l'Académie
française merci beaucoup de passer
l'heure avec nous on va parler du monde
d'avant c'est votre dernier livre chez
Grasset cette France perdue engloutie
celle de vos souvenirs d'enfants la
Nièvre et le petit village d'un fille
près de Nevers c'est la terre de votre
grand-père metalo résistant on va en
parler vous lui devez beaucoup qu'est-ce
que vous lui devez précisément vous
allez nous le dire ce soir dans la
deuxième partie mais on va commencer
avec celle que l'on croyait inépuisable
l'eau les premières mesures de
restriction d'eau ont été annoncés cette
semaine la sécheresse en hiver bah des
records et nous oblige à changer nos
habitudes les premières touchées sont
évidemment les exploitations agricoles
comment peuvent-ils s'adapter les
agriculteurs c'est l'une des questions
de notre grand débat ce soir avant de
retrouver aux alentours de 20h15 nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris avec la
carte blanche de Nicole Ferroni ce soir
et puis Bourbon Express bien sûr
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée vous
êtes prêt Marc Lambron ça vous regarde
c'est parti
[Musique]
le changement climatique est donc entré
pleinement dans nos vies la sécheresse
record de cet hiver nous fait redouter
le pire pour l'été qui arrive on va
parler de l'eau qui manque cruellement à
nos agriculteurs ce soir comment
peuvent-ils s'adapter à quoi devront
nous renoncer bonsoir Jean-Baptiste
Moreau c'est un grand plaisir de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau vous êtes
agriculteur en Creuse éleveur de vaches
on vous connaît bien dans sa vous
regarde vous étiez députés jusque en
2022 débutant en marche de ce
département de la Creuse vous avez
accompagné je crois une fois de plus
j'ai envie de dire le président de la
République au salon de l'agriculture
vous nous direz si la sécheresse c'est
vraiment la première préoccupation Porte
de Versailles bonsoir Sabrina sebahi
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
député Europe Écologie Les Verts des
Hauts de Seine bonsoir Emma Ziza
bienvenue vous êtes hydrologue et
docteur de l'École des Mines de Paris
enfin bonsoir Serge Zaka bienvenue agro
climatologue dans une entreprise d'AG
intelligence qui s'appelle ITK c'est
bien ça alors je suis plus chez ITK
depuis une semaine
et ben voilà c'est corrigé Marc Lambron
vous qui aimez le monde rural votre
livre en témoigne évidemment faites le
bienvenu vous pouvez intervenir quand
vous le souhaitez on va commencer avec
le billet de Stéphane Stéphane
blackovski pour nous planter le décor
comme chaque soir sécheresse état
d'urgence le tout en deux secondes le
chrono de la côte tout de suite
et je vous retrouve pour vous accueillir
comme chaque soir on sort Myriam bonsoir
à toutes
estrade c'est à vous alors début de
l'année tu vas présenter sur une estrade
à côté d'un grand très grand je me suis
dit mais ça va pas faire à peu
présentateur météo et ben nous y voilà
regardez j'y suis face à la météo de
samedi matin regardez GRAND beau temps
sur la Côte d'Azur du soleil sur les
trois quarts de la France même ceux qui
restent à Paris je crois que c'est vodka
il n'y aura pas de pluie donc bonne
nouvelle bof ben non pas du tout pas
bonne nouvelle regardez le graphique qui
explique ah il est pas très sexiste
graphique mais en fait ce qui souligne
c'est que depuis fin janvier jusqu'à fin
février pendant 32 jours et bien il a
plu moins de 2 mm sur le territoire
français c'est un record absolu Météo
France n'avait jamais mesuré ça donc
sans critiquer les graphistes de Météo
France peut-être que des photos rendent
mieux compte de l'état actuel de ce qui
se passe en France vous voyez que c'est
un peu dans différents endroits
la Garonne il y a vraiment une situation
alarmante ce qui est d'autant plus grave
c'est que le corps de sécheresse de
l'hiver il arrive après une sécheresse
historique qui a eu lieu l'été dernier
tout le monde s'en souvient ce qui fait
que alors que l'hiver les nappes
souterraines devraient se remplir et ben
elles ne remplissent pas il y a un
graphique tu le montres assez bien voyez
en janvier donc de ce cette année il y
avait 60 % des nappes phréatiques qui
étaient en dessous de la normale donc
beaucoup plus que l'an dernier la même
époque trois fois plus quasiment que
l'an dernier à la même époque alors que
faire bon heureusement on a un ministre
ça c'est c'est quand même dans ces
circonstances là bien utile il avait
prévu un plan de gestion de l'eau en
septembre qu'il est toujours pas prêt
donc là il a fallu réagir dans l'urgence
que fait-on dans l'urgence quand on est
ministre on convoque les préfets qui
sont chargés de l'eau on tape du point
sur la table et on leur retient un
langage de fermeté en écoute
en mars dans chaque département vous
réunissez un comité départemental
ressources en eau on fait une
photographie département par département
et partout où il y a besoin on prend les
arrêtés de restriction qui s'imposent on
n'a pas la main qui tremble bon bah
voilà quand il y a plus d'eau qu'est-ce
qu'on fait et ben il faut l'économiser
d'ailleurs les restrictions il y en a
déjà qui ont été prises il y a 5
départements qui sont déjà concernés par
ces mesures par exemple les
Bouches-du-Rhône il faudra que ils sont
sous restriction depuis l'été dernier il
y a toujours une forme de restriction ça
n'a jamais vraiment changé alors bien
sûr quand il faut restreindre la
consommation on sait bien qu'on doit
chacun faire un effort mais les jours
tenter de montrer celui qui consomme
plus que vous en l'occurrence on sait
que ceux qui consomment le plus c'est
l'agriculture donc les agriculteurs même
si regardez pour ce qui est de refroidir
les centrales électriques ça aussi ça
consomme et quand on regarde dans
l'agriculture là on utilise vraiment
beaucoup d'eau c'est on le sait
d'ailleurs on a le chiffre à 41% pour le
maïs qui sert principalement à nourrir
du bétail donc forcément ça fait un
petit peu ah je vois qu'il aime les yeux
au ciel depuis Jean-Baptiste Moreau mais
vous allez forcément justement en parler
donc puisqu'il faut faire peser un peu
de restriction sur l'agriculture ce qu'a
dit le président quand il était au salon
c'est qu'il faut quand même pas tout
mettre sur l'eau des agriculteurs bien
sûr que non c'est la nation qui doit
faire un effort on l'écoute la nation a
besoin de faire sur l'eau comme on l'a
fait sur l'énergie une forme de plantes
se briété c'est à dire qu'on doit tous
nous citoyen industriel service
collectivité locale agriculteurs faire
attention cette ressource qui deviendra
c'est ce que je disais en fin d'été
c'est la fin de l'abondance il avait dit
le président il avait prévu le coup en
quelque sorte après tout pourquoi pas un
plan de sobriété sur le regardez il y a
eu un plan de sobriété sur l'énergie sur
l'électricité ça plutôt bien fonctionné
là on parle au niveau des particuliers
vous voyez de consommer son de chacun ça
a bien baissé dans le Sud-Ouest un peu
moins dans le Nord mais il y a un effort
qui est possible donc si ça a marché
pour l'électricité pourquoi pas sur ça
ne marcherait pas sur l'eau donc
forcément si vous voulez faire un effort
chez vous je je vais vous donner un
conseil par Cambon je ne sais pas si on
arrête de faire des économies c'est
manifestement sur les questions des
douches et des bains qu'on peut faire un
effort si on veut faire un effort
personnel je vais pas vous quitter sans
vous donner une bonne nouvelle regardez
puisque je fais la météo ça c'est pas le
temps du samedi qui vient c'est le temps
du samedi après et là quel bonnes
nouvelles hein oui Ken plus vieux on va
pouvoir rester enfermé chez nous il
pleuvra il pleuvra il pleuvra quel
bonheur le 11 mars prochain de la pluie
sur tout le pays ça va pas suffire et
maladie là c'est du jamais vu ce qu'on
traverse aujourd'hui cette sécheresse en
hiver liée au réchauffement climatique
oui ce qui vit à mes puces c'est surtout
en fait cette année 2022 et ce cumule
avec cette arrivée en 2023 en 2022 au
mois de mars on était déjà dans un état
où on comprenait qu'on allait vivre une
année exceptionnelle mais là on vient
d'avoir c'est moi qui se succède et qui
à un moment donné nous raconte une
nouvelle histoire de la France une
France qui à la base est un pays tempéré
qui n'a jamais manqué d'eau 512
milliards de qui tombe annuellement le
2/3 repart dans l'atmosphère il nous en
reste largement assez pour qu'on soit de
grands consommateurs d'eau et donc
aujourd'hui ça nous demande en fait
d'être à l'heure des choix des choix
économiques puisque derrière la question
de l'eau se pose la question de filière
économique donc qui est-ce qu'on va
privilégier lorsqu'on voit par exemple
l'année dernière le lac de Serre-Ponçon
qui est encore dans un état bien plus
grave à l'heure actuelle où on parle et
bien effectivement il était déjà moins
17 mètres et là il fallait choisir entre
d'un côté une économie touristique à la
valve une économie agricole qui avait
besoin de cette eau et puis on oublie
bien souvent que c'était un barrage
hydroélectrique qui fournit aussi de
l'électricité dans une période crise
mondiale on va venir aux solutions à
l'adaptation on comprend que voilà tout
le monde va devoir forcément changer les
usages Serge Zaka la fin de l'abondance
est-ce qu'elle est justifiée cette
expression là la fin de l'abondance de
l'eau on comprend que la situation était
tellement mauvaise dans l'étape nappe
phréatique que quel que soit en fait des
précipitations c'est très compliqué pour
les recharger là pour pour le Printemps
Été qui vient alors ce qui est paradoxal
dans dans les prévisions du GIEC vous
déjà dire que pour l'eau il y a une
incertitude beaucoup plus importante que
pour la température mais si on observe
en fait les prévisions du GIEC celles
qu'on récupère du Dryas c'est un site
officiel de l'État on regarde qu'il y a
la même quantité d'eau qui peut tomber
sur l'année voire même ces dernières
années c'est 60 dernières années on a
plus 10% à peu près d'eau qui tombe sur
le nord de la France donc on peut se
dire bah on a de l'eau pourquoi on parle
de fin d'abondance mais c'est que cette
eau elle ne tombe plus au même moment
dans l'année il y a une partie d'après
les prisons déjà qui devraient tomber un
petit peu plus en hiver et un petit peu
moins en été et ça veut dire que sur la
saison culturelle qui se déroule en
général au printemps et en été on aura
moins d'eau et autre chose encore c'est
qu'on a les vapo transpiration ce fameux
terme un peu technique l'évaporation la
transpiration qui est augmentée à cause
de la température qui augmente donc on a
à peu près la même quantité d'eau qui
devrait tomber sur la France un petit
peu moins sur l'année au sud un petit
peu plus sur des années au nord mais sur
le c'est à peu près la même quantito
elle est juste répartie différemment sur
l'année et il y a plus des vapo
transpiration et elle tombera en plus
forte quantité quand elle tombera et les
sols n'auront pas d'eau et donc au final
si en mars il pleut là il faudrait quoi
200 mm de pluie tous les jours pour
recharger les nappes pas tous les jours
c'est 200 mm de plus sur l'ensemble du
mois de mars ce serait très intéressant
bien sûr il y aura une grande partie qui
rentrera pas dans le sol parce que ce
sera une grande quantité d'eau qui tombe
mais on a tellement de retard que il
faudrait battre tous les records de
précipitation du mois de mars sur
l'ensemble de la France pour rattraper
notre retard autant vous dire que pour
les nappes phréatiques c'est peine perdu
parce que d'ici le mois de mars elle ne
se rechargeront pas voilà il faut
changeront pas mais peut-être quand même
la pluie bon personne ne peut savoir va
quand même faire du bien si elle est là
pour les pour les agriculteurs pour les
sols si elle est là elle peut en
profondeur elle peut limiter les dégâts
au niveau des nappes phréatiques on
atteindra pas la norme mais pour les
sols agricoles c'est différent ça dépend
des départements discuter avec quelques
climatologues hier dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales même s'il replay de
façon normale on ne rechargera pas les
notes les sols sur les deux premiers
mètres là je parle des deux premiers
mètres par contre ce qui est intéressant
c'est que sur la plupart des régions
s'il pleut ça peut permettre sur les 40
premiers centimètres d'avoir de l'eau
donc pour le blé pour les semis ça peut
permettre d'éviter de pomper les réactif
et d'avoir de l'irrigation et c'est
important il faut éviter de pomper dans
ses nappes phréatiques aller en mettre
de l'eau en surface
quelle irrigation et sa relance
évidemment la question des méga bassines
Jean-Baptiste Moreau vous étiez au salon
de l'agriculture c'est le sujet
principal de préoccupation il y en a
beaucoup hein c'est un des sujets
principaux parce que les agriculteurs
sont les premiers à exposés au
changement climatique et cette réduction
d'eau d'ailleurs ils ont commencé à
s'adapter ils commencent déjà davantage
faire de culture diverses c'est-à-dire
des cultures qui sont implantées à
l'automne et récoltées à la fin du
printemps en début de l'été la période
où comme le disait Serge Zakar on a
globalement d'une année sur l'autre
alors sauf cette année évidemment mais
globalement on a plus d'eau à cette
période là donc ça permet une meilleure
concentration tout à l'heure sur
quel est le niveau d'inquiétude
aujourd'hui est-ce que déjà les réc sont
menacés par cette sécheresse alors les
récoltes de céréales pas encore pas
forcément encore bon il y a pas eu
encore vraiment d'impact après si
vraiment il pleut pas au mois de mars
oui il y en aura et toute façon
évidemment c'est une inquiétude parce
que sans eau il y a pas de vie qu'elle
soit végétale ou animale alors on va pas
renouveler le débat entre le végétal et
l'animal là c'est même pas une question
de de de choix entre la ou l'autre c'est
qu'aujourd'hui s'il y a pas d'eau il y
aura pas de plus de vie végétale que
devient animal demain et la vocation des
agriculteurs c'est c'est pas de semer
pour se faire plaisir et pour toucher
des aides à la fin c'est c'est de semer
pour avoir du rendement pour pouvoir
nourrir la population et on a ce morceau
là politiquement là on a vu dans les
mesures les dans les départements en
rouge sécheresse un Pyrénées-Orientales
Isère Var les agriculteurs doivent aussi
faire faire des efforts pas plus de
prélèvement de 50% de leur eau est-ce
que ça vous convient tout le monde doit
faire des efforts dans l'urgence
d'irrigation mise en place réellement au
jour d'aujourd'hui l'hiver il y a pas
d'irrigation l'irrigation elle commence
à arriver à partir du mois de mai quand
les périodes de
sécheresse ce cumule mais de toute façon
une chose est claire c'est que les
agriculteurs n'ont pas le droit d'autre
choix que s'adapter avec ce manque d'eau
puisque aujourd'hui ils font face tous
les jours et ça date pas d'hier ça date
de quelques années déjà ou les
déséquilibres effectivement les mêmes si
les quantités d'eau sur l'année sont à
peu près les mêmes la répartition est
très différente avec une eau qui tombe
surtout l'hiver et qui tombe très peu
l'été avec des grandes périodes de
sécheresse du mois de mai au mois de
septembre quasiment où là effectivement
ça commence à être difficile de faire
pousser quoi que ce soit y compris avec
de l'irrigation d'ailleurs alors Sabrina
c'est Bailly il y a du très court terme
très urgent on a vu les mesures de
restriction interdiction d'arroser les
plantes sauf vraiment quand c'est
absolument nécessaire interdiction dans
les départements concernés seulement et
bien de laver sa voiture
évidemment de remplir une piscine on est
dans la prévention pour éviter le pire
dans l'anticipation où on rattrape une
urgence qu'on n'a pas vu venir en fait
ça vient d'être dit ça fait très
longtemps ça fait déjà quelques années
qu'on sait ce qui nous attend et qu'on
voit les changements qui sont en train
de d'être visibles finalement c'était
les incendies tous l'été dernier les
sécheresses déjà délétées là les
sécheresses en hiver ce qui était ce qui
est quand même une première et en fait
on est dans un temps extrêmement grave
en réalité et nous on a plutôt le
sentiment que le gouvernement prend pas
la pleine mesure de ce qui est en train
de se passer et qu'on est effectivement
dans des réponses d'urgence dans
l'immédiateté même si un grand plan de
sobriété qui va de l'eau qui va être
annoncé en fait il arrive déjà trop tard
en réalité il y a une question
gouvernement ce mardi on nous expliquait
qu'on allait créer une cellule pour
anticiper la sécheresse anticipée quoi
on est déjà dans la sécheresse on est
déjà dans un temps et dans des
phénomènes extrêmement graves donc au
moment où on devrait dans la
planification justement écologique il
est utilisé ce mot-là oui mais par le
gouvernement j'espère bien qu'on va voir
quelque chose de ce fameux plan qui
devait être déjà prêt à la rentrée qui
ne l'est toujours pas alors qu'on est
justement en plein urgence aujourd'hui
qu'on ne voit pas de solutions
apparaître sur le long terme alors les
restrictions elles sont de bon sens mais
en réalité il y a plein de départements
où il aurait fallu ne jamais lever les
restrictions parce que déjà cet été on
avait des nappes phréatiques qui étaient
un niveau très bas je Jean-Baptiste
Moreau
tout à l'heure il manquait le chiffre
des fuites de sur les réseaux d'eau
parce qu'on a beaucoup de réseaux d'eau
et moi je parle en conscience de cause
dans mon département qui fuit à
quasiment 80 85 % c'est à dire entre le
prélèvement de l'eau et l'eau qui arrive
au robinet vous avez 80% du volume qui
part qui part dans des fuites parce
qu'on a un problème d'entretien
notamment dans les territoires ruraux où
vous avez assez peu de population au
kilomètre de tuyaux et où vous avez
globalement des petites communes de 140
150 habitants qui ont pas eu les moyens
dans les dans les 20 années compressées
de mettre au niveau et de mettre en état
leur réseau d'eau avec des fuites très
importantes et le premier eau qu'on va
économiser c'est celle qu'on gaspillera
pas justement et c'est celle qui on va
maintenir dans des tuyaux
on leur dit sobriété de l'eau on
découvre aussi que les eaux usées par
exemple alors il faut dire usées
apparemment c'est les eaux grises
retraitée et ben en fait ne sont pas du
tout utilisés alors on a 1% seulement
comment on explique ça c'est quoi c'est
les normes en Israël alors là on est
champion en la matière d'utilisation de
ces eaux c'est normal mais même en
Espagne ou en Italie ils font beaucoup
mieux que nous là-dessus alors sur
l'Espagne sur l'Italie c'est 8 à 15% 16%
de l'eau de l'eau un des villes qui est
réutilisée pour l'agriculture c'est un
système fermé on va dire
la France on en a pas eu la nécessité
parce que notre climat en fait ne nous
demandait pas de faire cette nécessité
là mais c'est qu'on n'a pas anticipé
suffisamment de le changement climatique
est là depuis 30 ans et c'est maintenant
qu'on se pose ces questions alors que ça
fait depuis 30 ans qu'on doit regarder
ce qui se passe en Italie en Espagne
pour anticiper et quand on parle de
mesure d'urgence parce qu'on est
toujours dans l'urgence on n'est même
pas dans l'anticipation quand on dit on
va anticiper en fait l'anticipation
c'est ce qui se passe pour moi dans 10
20 ans donc c'est réparer les fuites
pourquoi on les a pas réparés avant
quand on sait qu'il y a un changement
climatique qui arrive on s'est dit il y
a encore 20% de l'eau française qui est
perdu dans des fuites alors que ça fait
30 ans qu'on se dit qu'on va manquer
d'eau il y a des réseaux d'eau qui sont
communaux c'est à dire qui qui
desservent 140 habitants qui sont même
pas interconnectés avec d'autres réseaux
d'eau qui eux sont approvisionnés plus
enfin on est vraiment dans des
situations
des solutions et de l'adaptation comment
vous regardez ce débat marque Lambron la
sécheresse est-elle
à l'échelle du monde parce que si on
regarde l'Asie aujourd'hui on a plus
d'un milliard de personnes qui
consomment du riz en épuisant des nappes
phréatiques qui d'ici 10 ans
n'existeront plus ou est-ce qu'ils iront
se nourrir et donc ils se nourriront en
fin de compte sur les marchés mondiaux
et ils iront chercher leur blé ailleurs
on a aujourd'hui l'Egypte par exemple ou
la Tunisie qui ont un solde en eau qui
est négatif qui ne peuvent pas vivre
sans être approvisionnés par les autres
et donc nous on est aussi et surtout un
grand exportateur agricole indépendance
en tous les cas on l'est largement et
donc la question justement est-ce qu'on
se nourrit avec notre agriculture et
bien bien moins qu'on le pense on se
nourrit surtout avec nos supermarchés et
avec de la nourriture qu'on importe
emballé transformé et cette question de
l'eau virtuelle c'est une question qui
est cruciale parce qu'on se rend compte
que c'est toute la chaîne de valeur qui
est qui joue dessus quand on voit que
les grands barrages en Chine se sont
retrouvés vides l'année dernière et bien
ça a eu pour conséquence dans une
semaine qui ont suivi des arrêts d'usine
de jour par semaine et c'est toute la
chaîne de production qui s'est retrouvée
à l'arrêt donc en fin de compte on est
lié à l'eau d'ici on est relié à l'eau
d'ailleurs et les solutions qu'on nous
sort un petit peu comme par magie d'un
seul coup on a l'impression qu'on va
avoir de l'eau usée ça va être
fantastique moi j'étais la semaine
dernière en Israël j'ai voulu comprendre
dans l'état en quoi c'était les
champions du monde de la réutilisation
des eaux usées c'est quand même assez
intéressant de se rendre compte que ils
ont mis 20 ans de recherche et
développement actifs sans y arriver sans
y arriver c'est à dire qu'ils étaient au
dos ils étaient au pied du mur si je
puis dire et donc sur trois c'est en
technologie
ils en ont gardé que 20 qui fonctionnent
donc ça demande en fin de compte un
investissement colossal et ça fait 30
ans qu'on fait de la réutilisation des
eaux usées en France et on a 80 exemples
en France sauf que beaucoup se sont le
soldés par des échecs donc oui bien sûr
que c'est une solution intéressante mais
attention derrière ça va prendre du
temps il va falloir faire des essais des
erreurs et c'est pas la solution mais
alors vous avez vous amorcez le débat de
solutions je garde la question sur la
fracture sociale ne vous inquiétez pas
hydrographique on va on va y répondre
mais comment résister donc à cette
sécheresse certains agriculteurs
s'adaptent vous allez le voir dans ce
sujet s'il est Marion Becker
c'est un geste que ce maraîchers de la
Drôme fait habituellement au mois
d'avril alors là j'allume l'eau pour
irriguer les cultures d'hiver que nous
avons mis en place en cette fin février
le sol de ces terres est anormalement
fissuré par le manque d'eau alors pour
limiter l'arrosage et protéger sa
production il a mis en place des astuces
on essaie d'installer du pays entre les
rangées pour regarder une humidité du
sol on essaye aussi d'installer des
bâches en toile pour aussi garder une
humidité sous les cultures à quelques
mètres des serres dans ses champs même
problème
on peut essayer d'enfoncer son doigt etc
il y a pas possibilité de planter quoi
que ce soit là
[Musique]
isamment arrosé pour
planter courge
face à cette eau qui devient de plus en
plus rare comment s'adapter à la
sécheresse dans les champs les vignes
les élevages certains producteurs ont
changé de méthode
en Meurthe-et-Moselle cet éleveur de 80
vaches laitières nourrissait ses animaux
avec un fourrage à base de maïs cette
année il lui a préféré une semence moins
gourmand dans l'eau
c'est automne on a récolté un maïs
catastrophique en valeur mais aussi en
rendement donc concrètement on s'est dit
il faut arrêter de mettre de mise sur
cette parcelle là donc pour pallier au
manque de fourrage on met donc durée
gras et du Trèfle donc un mélange qui
permettra de nourrir les animaux et pour
abreuver ses vaches il a fait creuser un
forage pour puiser l'eau
phréatiques baisse donc on a besoin pour
maintenir l'élevage si on veut le
maintenir de garder la sérénité en ayant
une source d'eau à proximité
dans le Rhône cet arboriculteur lui a
investi dans un système d'arrosage pour
ses 10 hectares de cerisiers l'eau est
distribuée de manière ciblée au
goutte-à-goutte
ça permet de réduire les quantités
puisqu'on apporte l'eau uniquement au
pied de l'arbre il y a beaucoup moins
d'évaporation puis on arrive à
économiser 25 à 30% d'eau par rapport à
un système classique d'irrigation un
système qui a un coût
4500 euros par hectare le prix à payer
pour éviter la sécheresse
voilà il y a des alternatives on le voit
le goutte à goûte ou alors changer les
semences pour pour l'élevage pour pour
nourrir le bétail est-ce que ça c'est
suffisant où on est là vraiment dans des
solutions on va dire de sur mesure un
peu micro alors il faut savoir qu'il
existe pas et en général c'est toujours
le cas pour l'agriculture il n'existe
pas une solution miracle qui répondrait
à tous les besoins c'est un ensemble de
solutions qu'il faut mettre en place
pour gagner quelques pourcentages de dos
à chaque fois par exemple gagner 5 à 10%
d'eau dans les sols en travaillant moins
le sol et en ayant des couverts entre
deux cultures pour protéger le solfaire
de l'ombre et éviter les vapo
transpiration ça s'appelle l'agriculture
de conservation des sols ça permet de
gagner juste 5 à 10% de rétention de
l'eau dans les sols mais 5 à 10% dans le
cas du sécheresse c'est 7 jours ou 10
jours supplémentaires et c'est très
important par exemple si on est dans le
remplissage
oui il y a des il y a des inconvénients
à cette agriculture là il y a également
des variété des espèces qu'on peut
mettre en place qui consomment moins
d'eau sachant que les espèces il faut
aussi créer des filières derrière parce
que il y a pas forcément des espèces qui
sont présentes sur tous les territoires
et il y a également le système par
exemple de goutte à goutte sur des
techniques
de solutions parce que quand on les
entend jamais Cristiano Lambert de la
FNSE elle dit arrêtez là il va falloir
stocker et pour stocker et ben il va
falloir retenir et pour retenir il faut
aller creuser c'est la position de la
FNSEA est-ce que est-ce que vous vous
adhérez ou vous dites on a cette palette
et on peut piocher ça suffira c'est
effectivement une palette de solutions
et on a besoin de la mobilisation de
toute façon il y aura pas d'agriculture
sans eau et comme l'a dit Madame
aujourd'hui la vecteur à vocation à
nourrir et on nourrit de moins en moins
notre population parce qu'on importe de
plus en plus que ce qu'on ne produira
pas on apportera donc l'eau
l'agriculture a besoin d'eau de toute
façon c'est une panel de solutions les
réservescolinaires peuvent en être une
alors les méga bassines à condition que
ce sont cadrés que ce soit pour faire
métaux et n'importe quoi là dessous et
on met notamment d'ailleurs des réserves
préliminaires
culinaire qui ressemblent pas à ça et on
appelle ça des méga bestines aussi et il
y a aussi des associations
dans beaucoup de dans beaucoup
d'articles pour faire donc on a d'un
côté ce qu'on appelle les bassines ce
sont des retenues de substitution à 90%
d'entre elles elles vont être alimentées
principalement par l'eau qui est située
dans la nappe en dessous 10% sont
alimentés par le cours d'eau à côté le
fait d'aller piocher massivement dans la
nappe phréatique vous allez épuiser
complètement la nappe et on s'est rendu
compte il y a une étude qui est sortie
il y a deux mois qu'on s'était
complètement trompé sur l'analyse de
notre modèle du rôle de la nappe
phréatique non seulement elle alimente
tous les cours d'eau que vous voyez en
eau durant l'été lorsqu'il ne pleut pas
donc en réalité vous allez créer des
insectes beaucoup plus rapides et sur un
territoire bien plus large parce qu'en
réalité si vous baissez le niveau de la
nappe phréatique une nappe en général ça
s'étend parfois sur des centaines de
kilomètres donc il va y avoir un majeur
sur les cours d'eau mais surtout on
s'est rendu compte que l'humidité du sol
et notamment de la qualité pour
l'agriculture était fonction de la
hauteur de la nappe et donc si vous
épuisez rap en réalité vous allez encore
plus épuiser le sol vous allez prendre
cette eau vous allez la mettre en
surface elle va être de moins de qualité
parce qu'elle est dictation c'est-à-dire
elle va avoir un flux évaporatoire
important et avec les vagues de chaleur
successives qu'on a et bien ce flux
d'autant plus supérieur donc on a une
eau de moins de bonne qualité et qui ne
fonctionne pas donc juste pour terminer
autre point les retenus colinaires ce
sont des retenus il en existe à peu près
150 000 en France donc c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas construit on en a
beaucoup mais alors c'est quoi la
différence il y a des toutes petites il
y a les routes c'est simplement qu'on
récupère de l'eau de pluie et on crée
des sortes de mini barrages pour
empêcher cette eau d'arriver ensuite
dans le réseau hydrographique et donc de
rejoindre les rivières puis les fleuves
il faut juste faire attention à un piège
dans ces retenues colinéaires qui sont
une bonne solution en soi c'est que si
vous mettez des retenues colinaires
partout et bien à la fin vous n'avez
plus d'eau dans votre fleuve ça a été
l'exemple qui a été développé notamment
en Australie ils se sont piégés
eux-mêmes à force de trop récupérer
l'eau on n'avait plus d'eau dans les
fleuves qui alimentait les villes ça
Brenna sebahi oui retenue colinéaire à
condition
de le faire avec modération non Oméga
bassine c'est ça j'ai vu qu'il y avait
un mouvement déjà autour du 25 mars sur
le modèle de sainte oline dans les
Deux-Sèvres nous en tout cas ce qu'on
dit depuis le début c'est que les méga
bassines c'est vraiment la fausse bonne
idée parce que ça a été très bien
expliqué sur le fait de d'aller chercher
dans les nappes phréatiques et donc de
les mettre vraiment à plat complètement
et surtout en fait de capter l'eau
finalement pour quelques agriculteurs
parce que c'est quand même ça le sujet
ça a été évoqué la question du maïs qui
est en principal le principal
responsable de la plus grande
utilisation de en agriculture mais vous
souhaitez pas qu'on arrête le maïs en
France mais en fait il va falloir
forcément changer les postures alors
changer
[Musique]
sans irrigation parce qu'il y a pas
forcément d'irrigation entre je pense
qu'à un moment il va falloir qu'on
change le modèle agricole c'est évident
le maïs sert essentiellement à nourrir
ça a été dit le bétail donc ça pose
aussi la question de la consommation de
viande dans notre pays parce que c'est
c'est tout est en chaîne et la réalité
c'est que quand on parle d'anticiper de
changement c'est justement ces
questions-là qu'il faut qu'on se pose
c'est quel modèle agricole pour demain
comment ce qu'on fait avec la question
de la sécheresse et des questions des
températures parce que je crois que ça
c'est le 13e mois consécutif on est
au-dessus des normales saisonnières donc
en réalité il y a quand même un enjeu de
ce point de vue là et quand j'entends
mais c'est peut-être que le Président de
la République a donné le temps en début
de l'année quand il disait qui aurait pu
anticiper le changement climatique c'est
à dire qu'on est vraiment dans une
logique où on anticipe pas effectivement
c'est dans les 20 30 ans qu'il va
falloir réfléchir et là on est plutôt
dans on met des rustines
elle est sensible cette question pardon
Jean-Baptiste Moreau c'est un autre
la le 13 sensible cette question de du
changement de modèle agricole quand on
voit céréales qui sont très
consommateurs d'eau vous vous dites ce
serait l'agriculture souffre qu'on
produit déjà beaucoup moins ce serait
quoi ce serait la mise à mort de
l'agriculture française
tout à fait d'accord pour changer de
modèle ils l'ont déjà commencé à le
faire ils ont voilà ils ont pas attendu
qu'on leur dit explique comment il
fallait faire ils sont confrontés tous
les jours moi ce que je dis c'est que
les agriculteurs des discours simpliste
autour de l'agriculture de gens qui n'y
connaissent rien qui disent il y a qu'un
faucon l'agriculture ça se fait ça se
réagit pas avec des coups de la cafocon
ça vide c'est faire avec du vivant et
avec de la réalité et on ne se confronte
tous les jours à la réalité donc on
change effectivement ce qui doit être
changé parce que il faut s'adapter de
toute façon on n'a pas le choix si on
s'adapte pas on disparaît donc mais
après autour de l'agriculture il y a
tout un tas de solutions effectivement
il y a effectivement les réserves
culinaires et les réserves en eau qui
vont être nécessaires parce que pas
d'agriculture sans eau et après les
sélections variétales notamment les
nouvelles biotechnologies végétales qui
vont permettre de sélectionner des
variétés qui sont aussi moins gourmandes
en eau qui ont besoin de moins d'eau
pour faire de la croissance des
croissances suffisantes il faut
mobiliser la recherche absolument sur la
récupération des eaux usées et
l'utilisation des eaux usées c'est
effectivement un panel de solutions il
va se faire naturellement moins de maïs
parce que effectivement les il va pas on
va pas continuer à irriguer du maïs s'il
y a plus d'eau ça c'est la base il y a
pas d'eau on peut pas irriguer toute
façon donc donc voilà on est en train de
s'adapter mais ça se fait pas ça se
décrète pas et pas pudika faucon pour
terminer à quoi on va devoir renoncer
dans ce grand plan de sobriété
j'aimerais bien qu'on termine avec cette
question pour sortir un poil de
l'agriculture rebondir à la fois sur
nous et sur la question du maïs c'est
que le maïs au-delà du forage est
derrière de l'alimentation du bétail
derrière il fournit des économies
colossales le maïs et nos cosmétique le
maïs c'est nos papiers le maïs c'est
notamment la manière dont enfin les
matières plastiques donc en réalité il y
a énormément de formes de maïs et donc
il va falloir faire des choix faire des
choix parce que c'est un graminé
tropical qui n'a pas de racine profonde
qui a normalement en général plutôt
tendance à être irriguée en surface
parce que justement il ne peut pas aller
chercher cet autrement il va être
intéressant il va quand même être
important de réfléchir collectivement au
modèle de société qu'on a envie de créer
et les filières qu'on va qu'on va
choisir donc je crois que si on doit
parler de nous on va parler des choix
elle doit être quand même ressentie vous
parliez de la fracture sociale pour
terminer on parle on pense aux piscines
on pense au terrain de golf la guerre
des piscines c'est c'est efficace ou ça
n'est que raviver des tensions sociales
alors que alors que ça peut ça peut être
un symbole aussi
vous avez bien qui vous parlez j'habite
à Montpellier à Montpellier on regarde
une image satellite il y a des piscines
partout il y a des piscines municipales
et il y a des piscines individuelles et
quand je dis vieille une certaine forme
d'égoïsme aussi avec des gazons ouverts
avec des piscines remplies tout l'été
même en cas de restriction parce que la
police de l'eau n'est pas présente dans
toutes les dans toutes les rues et moi
j'ai déjà surpris des voisins à remplir
la piscine et réguler leur gazon il y a
une certaine forme d'égoïste qui qui
naît une fracture sociale qui naît de
cette de cette égoïsme des personnes qui
ont les moyens
peuvent se transformer en lutte des
classes
déjà parce que c'est déjà une situation
pour terminer et après peut-être qu'on
peut aussi réinventer le nouveau modèle
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a beaucoup de
piscine on peut très bien créer des
piscines naturelles qui peuvent devenir
des réserves de biodiversité si on
décidait d'autoriser ce genre là de
piscine et peut-être de cliver plus tôt
celle qui n'apportent rien à part un
confort individuel on irait aussi dans
un sens où c'est pas juste l'un ou
l'autre alors je vais donner le mot de
la fin allez-y parce que tout soit
démocratique quand même j'imagine voir
les plus puissants et les plus riches
qui polluent le plus et qui en fait ont
le plus d'impact sur la question
climatique donc aujourd'hui parler des
piscines c'est comme si on parlait des
jets ou enfin vraiment on est dans un
décalage total entre ceux qui ont très
peu qui utilisent très peu d'eau en
réalité et ceux qui se gavent de cette
eau jusqu'à plus soif et en réalité
c'est ça qu'il faut et on a besoin de
demander plus d'efforts à ceux qui
consomment plus d'eau aujourd'hui quel
regard juste pour conclure juste une
c'est un point de conclusion nous
n'avons pas parlé des poissons c'est à
dire des ressources aliotiques car l'eau
elle est aussi vivrière et comme la
faune notamment à vierres qui est autour
de l'eau allons nous manquer de poisson
et de fruits de mer la question est
aussi ouverte et liée à l'eau et vous en
parlez d'ailleurs beaucoup des pêcheurs
que votre grand-père
merci beaucoup on s'arrête là merci à
vous d'être venu débattre vous restez
avec moi Marc Lambron dans une dizaine
de minutes elles sont fin prêtes nos
affranchis au féminin pluriel ce soir la
carte blanche de Nicole Ferroni que vous
reconnaissez l'oeil sur le numérique de
Delphine Sabatier et puis Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
racontée par Elsa mondingava à toute à
l'heure mesdames mais d'abord on plonge
je le disais dans la vie de ce village
de la Nièvre infie près de Nevers le
monde d'avant chez graphès c'est un
texte court c'est un texte dense et
c'est un texte poétique on en parle
juste après l'invitation signée ce soir
par Marco 1er riche de votre parcours
vous l'aide sans aucun doute Marc
Lambron conseiller d'État journaliste
écrivains vous êtes un observateur
attentif de la vie politique on
retiendra surtout votre élection à la
prestigieuse Académie française depuis
on vous surnomme le rockeur de
l'Académie référence à votre passion
pour ce style musical vous savez des
grands académiciens comme Jean Cocteau
par exemple tenait dans leur jeunesse la
batterie du Jazz Band du buff sur le
toit donc l'Académie française voyez
elle est elle est elle est rock et elle
est seule à l'occasion loin du rock'n
roll vous revenez dans votre livre sur
les rites d'un monde mirural mis ouvrier
autant de votre grand-père à un fille
dans la Nièvre une cité d'acier du 20e
siècle une petite bourgade où l'égalité
régnée entre les Camaro les camarades
ouvriers où l'on voté rouge communiste
tout en gardant un lien affectif avec
l'Église alors Marc Lambron après cet
hommage au patois au coutume au mérite
de ce monde d'hier cette question
finalement est-ce que c'était mieux
avant
réponse
alors je vous dirai non d'abord c'était
pas mieux avant parce que je parle de
mon grand-père est venu en 1902 donc il
a connu deux guerres mondiales ce qui
n'est pas rien c'est un monde où la
sécurité social n'existe pas vraiment
c'est un monde de la condition ouvrière
est extrêmement
âpre il occupera d'ailleurs avec ses
camarades de la l'usine en 1936 donc
c'est un monde de conquête de de rudesse
ça c'est une chose mais ce qui me semble
différent en quelque sorte et peut-être
mieux alors à ce moment-là ce sont les
attitudes ce sont les éthiques
personnelles et solidaire fasse
précisément à la contingence et à la
dureté de l'existence vous écrivez par
delà son étrange T qui accroît la
distance le monde d'avant me retient par
ces harmonies transmises les silences de
son courage sa pudeur
l'harmonie le courage la pudeur c'est
tout ce n'est pas notre époque
aujourd'hui ce qui me frappe dans ce
monde qui était en effet assez
conflictuel d'abord c'est l'amitié qui
était une vraie valeur les Camaro dont
on parlait tout à l'heure ce monde mixte
en effet où les femmes vont à l'église
mais lorsqu'il y a des obsèques les
hommes restent sur le parvis la
casquette à la main silencieux a
tendance et mon grand-père disait on a
bien le temps de pas lire donc on est on
est rouge voilà on me lit toujours tôt
ou tard
voilà après ce qui me frappe oui c'est
que j'ai connu c'est c'est lors de mes
vacances d'enfance
souvenir d'enfance vous n'avez pas vécu
peut-être il faut l'expliquer à ceux qui
nous regarde
à Genève de sa soeur mais moi en effet
j'ai passé les les mois de juillet
puisque mes parents vivaient à vivaient
à Lyon
j'ai pas le souvenir d'un ressentiment
c'est à dire que je crois que le
l'honneur de de mes grands-parents et de
leurs amis dans cette vie semi rurale
semi-industrielle c'était de ne pas
céder sur le luxe le luxe du du bonheur
et l'égalité alors c'était les petits
bonheurs si vous voulez c'est à dire le
le bal les déjeuners du dimanche le
cirque qui passe mais il y avait alors
c'est vrai aussi que c'est les trentes
glorieuses à partir de 45 donc il y a
l'avenir est posé comme espoir il est
pas posé comme péril alors on va y aller
on va regarder à nouveau cette carte
postale
dans la Nièvre il y a cette anecdote
cette anecdote quand vous rencontrez
pour la première fois François
Mitterrand c'est lors d'une réception à
l'Elysée 1991 voilà sur la 4 où ça se
situe et François Mitterrand l'ont
emmerde Château-Chinon dans la Nièvre il
faut le rappeler vous lui expliquez que
votre famille maternelle est originaire
d'un fille le président ferme les yeux
là où sont les hautes cheminées il a dit
peu il a tout dit oui ça c'est ce que
vous dites
frappante d'ailleurs de silhouetter ce
que pouvait être pour quelqu'un qui qui
descendait la loi ou qui longeait la
route nationale de passer vous voyez vu
général de de l'usine et l'usine est
toujours en activité aujourd'hui alors
oui parce que le fabrique des aciers
spéciaux donc elle n'a pas connu comme
d'autres la crise de la moins que
d'autres et par exemple on m'a dit que
dans les sondes spatiales qui vont vers
Mars il y a des compos qui ont été
usinés à un fille j'indique aussi
j'indique aussi que la spationaute
française future Sophie Adnot et bien
ses grands-parents étaient de la fille
et son arrière-grand-mère était la
marraine de ma grand-mère donc on
fabrique des aciers spéciaux aussi dans
la trente des caractères parlons de
votre grand-père Pierre Denis vous le
disiez né en 1902 orphelin Compagnon du
Devoir il devient apprenti maçon et
tailleur de pierre avant de rejoindre la
série d'un fille après son service
militaire en Algérie qui était-il et que
vous a-t-il transmis alors je l'ai connu
je l'ai connu âgé et veuf donc c'est un
homme qui avait perdu sa femme
prématurément elle avait disparu à 55
ans ma grand-mère donc il était
assis-turn il était
émerveillé encore par des choses il
aimait les aimants il aimait le
transistor les dessins animés la
télévision télévision en noir et blanc
des années 60 avec les les Camaro qui
regardaient les matchs de foot avec le
rouler de la de la Bourgogne donc au
frais
et le patois et ma mère qui commence
ayant eu son bac ce qui était
extrêmement méritoire en 1949 dans cette
ville de 3000 habitants il y a trois
bacheliers qui sont des bacheliers elle
commence comme institutrice remplaçante
dans du bourgade du Morvan et elle a
affaire à des des jeunes enfants fils de
bûcheron ou de paysans qui ne parlent
que le qui parle de patois comme langue
première donc on est encore au 19e
siècle on est encore dans la
l'alphabétisation du coupé
cette dimension là ça raconte une beauté
une beauté de la langue s'il vous dit
qu'une barboulotte c'est une coccinelle
c'est assez joli si je vous dis qu'un
arcier c'est un frelon si je vous dis
qu'un Berlot c'est quelqu'un qui parle
trop voilà c'est blush pour les asticots
pour la pêche de votre grand-père
absolument le Bota c'est la bourriche
qui était un homme extrêmement engagé un
rouge on l'a dit un communiste et mais
engagé aussi pour pour ses camarades
ouvriers
il a refusé dans un premier temps de
changer de maison parce qu'il allait
devenir contre-maître et ça c'est pas
rien parce que il voulait pas lâcher
c'est en 1934 il y a un certain
paternalisme ouvrier d'ailleurs les
rapports sont assez ambiguë entre
patronat et et syndicat mais oui une
cité ouvrière est construite en 1934 la
condition c'est d'y accéder pour y
accéder c'est d'être contremaître il
refuse parce qu'il ne veut pas commander
à ses camarades et il se fiche de
l'argent mais sa femme lui dit Pierre
c'est pas toi qui tient la queue de la
poêle il y a souvent comme ça des
sentences de ma grand-mère que j'ai à
peine connue et une sentence capitale
elle disait à ses filles vous n'êtes ni
plus ni moins que les autres ça veut
dire que ni moins que les autres c'est
une définition qui porte d'abord à la
une certaine humilité et en même temps
qu'il laisse ouvert l'espoir précisément
d'être comme d'être comme tout le monde
alors avec aussi une chose qui est je
crois typique des 30 glorieuses c'est la
foi qui le mettait dans la l'institution
scolaire au fond les études les bourses
permettent permettent de monter ou de
s'élever et quand leur fille a permis
votre mère était brillante elle est
brillante poussière elle a pu aller à de
perdre oui mais alors quand même pas
toujours été simple pour votre père
pour mon père non parce que
son émancipation comme une évidence non
absolument mais les femmes n'étaient pas
les jeunes femmes n'étaient pas n'était
pas discriminées simplement quand elle
va quand elle est prise comme boursière
et interne dans un collège à Nevers
section grec et latin mon grand-père un
peu dubitatif tu dis mais est-ce que tu
vas nourrir ton mari avec ça mais
néanmoins il l'accepte et le latin qui
est au fond un superflu ou une élégance
en même temps ça fait partie précisément
de la de la constitution de l'honnête
femme ou de l'honnêtetum tel qu'il
pouvait les voir que l'école l'éducation
le travail aussi est une valeur pour ce
couple de grands-parents il a noblé
l'homme on est tous redevables un peu à
ceux qui qui nous ont précédés et vous
payez en quelque sorte une forme de
dette que vous assumez d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui quelle est cette dette alors
la dette c'est que c'est la droiture je
crois c'est à dire que j'ai pas de je ne
vois pas dans ces dans pour autant
qu'elle m'a été rapporté que j'ai pu les
voir je ne vois rien de médiocre en
somme et je ne vois rien de tordue
comment dirais aujourd'hui donc à ça et
puis il y a en effet la
il désignait à leurs héritiers la voix
du Mérite bon donc moi j'ai pas grand
mérite précisément à avoir comme ma mère
passait des concours de la République
voilà n'importe quel concours en ce qui
est beaucoup plus
je suis devenu agrégé de l'être donc
j'ai pris aussi cette cette voie là et
avoir vu le jour loin des hauts
mais c'est vrai que je vis avec l'idée
que j'aurais pu être approuvé
c'est-à-dire que voilà il y a la
présence invisible de ce qu'il de ce
qu'ils auraient voulu et je crois que
j'ai pas j'ai pas trop dévié donc je me
sens à la fois redevable et obligé en
quelque sorte devant leur souvenir un
dernier mot on croit parfois conquérir
avant de comprendre que l'on retrouve
oui parce que vous écrivez
aussi parce que j'ai à peu près l'âge
qu'avait mon grand-père quand je l'ai
connu enfant donc je mesure mieux
peut-être que c'est que la durée d'une
vie humaine et ça me met d'autant plus
en situation de comprendre ou d'essayer
de d'aller de revenir dans leur jardin
parce que c'est le petit Marc qui
revient dans le dans le jardin de ses
grands-parents finalement et avec quel
style et avec quel plus merci beaucoup
merci Marc le monde d'avant chez Grasset
c'est un très beau texte vous l'avez
compris un hommage à ce que vous appelez
je cite l'unicité épique de la vie voilà
c'est très beau moins fracturé peut-être
moins malheureuse ou moins douloureuse
qu'elle le sont aujourd'hui merci vous
restez avec moi c'est la dernière partie
de l'émission C'est l'heure des parties
pris de nos affranchis elles sont trois
ce soir et on les accueille tout de
suite
Nicole Ferroni bienvenue vous allez vous
parler du chômage je crois ce soir tout
à fait bonsoir Delphine Sabatier bonsoir
de Bismarck vous revenez du salon
mondial du téléphone mobile à Barcelone
on voit ça dans un instant mais on
commence comme chaque soir avec Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
nous est racontée par elsament d'un GABA
ce soir bonsoir Elsa bonsoir je vais
vous raconter l'histoire d'un texte
rejeté alors vous me direz à l'Assemblée
ça peut arriver rien de nouveau mais là
c'est un texte de la majorité rejeté par
la majorité j'espère que j'ai guise un
peu absolument de quel texte s'agit-il
et bien écoutez ce texte est une
proposition de loi qui était défendue
par neyma muchu qui est député horizon
vous savez le parti d'Edouard Philippe
elle entendait créer des peines plancher
alors dans un cas particulier pour les
délits commis contre les personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique et
en cas de récidive il était débattu dans
le cadre de la niche du groupe horizon
vous le savez les groupes minoritaires
ils ont une journée ici à l'Assemblée
pour proposer les lois qu'il souhaite
donc on rappelle un horizon c'est le
soutenu par Édouard Philippe tous ses
proches à l'Assemblée il y a trois
groupes dans la majorité il en fait
partie à côté du groupe Renaissance les
les macronistes et le et le modem de
François Bayrou alors pourquoi ce texte
pourtant dans la majorité n'a pas n'a
pas été adopté alors il a pas été adopté
il a même été franchement retoqué par le
garde des sceaux Eric Dupont-Moretti
l'article 1 a été rejeté un peu après
midi pourquoi et bien parce que les
députés renaissants sont voté contre et
ils assument ce choix écouter Sacha
olier c'est le président de la
commission des lois
qu'est-ce que c'est dit des relations
entre horizons et Renaissance c'est
quand même pas le beau fixe ce que ça
dit simplement c'est que sur la question
des peines plancher à laquelle nous
avons toujours été posé nous avons
réitéré une position qui est une
position constante depuis six ans qui
était la position des membres de la
majorité dans la presse scientifique la
nature et qui n'a pas évolué dans cette
législature ci c'est eux qui ont changé
la vie de mon point de vue oui puisque
ces dispositions nous ne les avons
jamais soutenu ni jamais adopté
précédemment voilà simple différence
d'appréciation pour les députés
Renaissance coup de poignard pour les
députés horizons qui a été obligé de
retirer son texte et qui déboule en
groupe salle des quatre colonnes ils n'y
vont pas de main morte pour critiquer
l'attitude de leurs collègues
Renaissance
est-ce que vous en voulez au groupe
qu'on va se venger je sais pas le but je
pense que le groupe Renaissance a tort
aujourd'hui
et il a tort profondément et il n'athore
pas vis-à-vis du groupe horizon pas
vis-à-vis de l'hémicycle il a tort
vis-à-vis des Français il est dans une
situation où il est à côté de la réalité
on la voit Naima mucho était à côté du
président de son groupe elle a dénoncé
des coups tordus on lui a demandé plus
d'explications
qui n'est pas envie de d'entendre parler
de peine minimale qui fasse l'amalgame
avec les peines plancher 2007 pourquoi
pas ça c'est le débat de fond il faut
l'avoir d'ailleurs j'étais prête à
l'avoir je l'ai dit c'est pas le
problème c'est tout ce qu'il y a autour
voilà c'est les petites manœuvres les
petits coups de procédure qui n'ont pas
leur place quand on est dans la même
famille politique justement est-ce que
ça va laisser des traces dans votre
famille politique vous vous êtes du
groupe horizon est-ce que avec vos
camarades du groupe Renaissance les
relations vont un petit peu se tendre
moi je vous l'ai dit je suis une
énervable mais je prends acte et je
n'oublie rien
une énervable mais rancunière un peu
rancunière ah oui ça balance on sent
bien que c'est pas simple entre ces deux
groupes ils vont être rancuniers donc
les partisans d'Edouard Philippe à
l'Assemblée vous avez entendu ils sont
inervables c'est ce qui aime répéter
l'ancien Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe puisque évidemment il est à la
même œuvre derrière tout ça écoutez la
confidence d'un député Renaissance
Édouard Philippe en polloche il est
imbattable poloch comprendre politique
politicienne pourquoi parce que derrière
il y a un petit peu de stratégie on le
sait horizon le parti d'Edouard Philippe
pour l'instant il est amarré à la
majorité mais un jour il va prendre le
large pourquoi et bien pour justifier
d'une candidature d'Édouard Philippe en
2017 et pour ça et bien il a besoin de
se démarquer de prendre un peu de
distance là il se démarque sur la droite
en reprenant un marqueur de droite ça
tombe bien Édouard Philippe croix au
clivage au retour du clivage gauche
droite en tout cas ça va pas réchauffer
ses relations avec le président de la
République Marc Lambron il pose des
jalons déjà bah il faut 2027 Edouard
Philippe il faut deux ailes pour voler
mais quand il y en a une qui attaque
l'autre évidemment ça pose des problèmes
à l'oiseau
vous avez l'impression que voilà Édouard
Philippe
pourrait incarner la France que vous
décrivez si bien dans ce livre en tout
cas une partie d'entrée écoutez le Havre
il y a des des chantiers navals il y a
au moins quelque chose de six
idéologique alors je sais pas si c'est
un homme sidérurgique lui-même un homme
de fer ça nous nous verrons nous verrons
plus tard et puis un bal des prétendants
quand même il y a quelques étapes à
franchir
Nicole Ferroni oui carte blanche sur le
chômage ce soir exactement moi je vais
vous parler du chômage en France parce
que alors je sais que ça vous étonner
mais en fait en ce mois de mars 2023 il
y a toujours du chômage en France et
alors en quoi c'est étonnant c'est lié
au fait que comme le décret de la
dernière réforme de l'assurance chômage
a été publié déjà un mois c'est
normalement logiquement on aurait dû
s'attendre à ce que durant ce mois
écoulé et ben les chômeurs de France
bousculés revigorer par cette réforme
est déjà tous retrouvé le chemin de
l'enthousiasme et de l'emploi et ce
n'est pas le cas alors pour rappel cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage défendue
par le ministre du Travail monsieur
dussoft donc je vais rappeler le
principe principe de la réforme pas
principe du ministre puisque je ne sais
pas s'il en a consiste en je cite
durcissement de l'indemnisation chômage
depuis le 1er février en diminuant cette
durée d'indemnisation de 25% pour rendre
je cite le système plus incitatif
sous-entendu il y a des emplois à portée
de main des chômeurs et il ne les
prennent pas comme si les chômeurs
étaient un peu vous savez comme ces
enfants dans un manège qui ne se lèvent
pas comme ça pour attraper le pompon et
moi justement j'ai un ami qui qui tient
un manège et qui donc voilà donc je
voyais qu'il perdait du temps à tendre
le pompon ils ont un Zouzou dans une
maison entre mes 12 le pompon et je lui
avais proposé une stratégie à la manière
de Monsieur du soft pour alors qu'il
durcisse non pas organisation de ces
gens enfin qui saisissent un emploi mais
qui durcissent le comment dire l'assise
des vous savez dans le manège afin
d'inciter ces enfants à se lever pour
choper le pompon alors c'est voilà je
vais vous proposer vraiment une
stratégie qui durcisse à la manière du
sol c'est à dire un peu dur c'est à dire
j'avais proposé carrément que sur les
sièges on met on met des petits clous
alors évidemment pas des gros clous
parce qu'on est sur des enfants donc ça
voilà quand même mais suffisamment pour
que dès que les enfants aient envie de
chômer donc de s'asseoir ça leur pique
les fesses et ils ont envie de choper
l'emploi le pompon pardon alors
figurez-vous que mon idée n'a pas été
accepté d'abord parce qu'elle est
illégale on n'a pas le droit de faire du
mal à un enfant et aussi parce
qu'apparemment elle était sadique ce que
j'entends cela dit et l'argument qui
mettait opposé c'était de dire mais
Nicole si encore il y avait un nombre
équivalent d'enfants et de pompons 8
enfants 8 pompons là ce serait une
mesure incitative car chacun des entrées
voilà de se mobiliser et d'attraper le
pompon mais quand il y a à la base qu'un
seul pompon pour huit enfants de en fait
c'est condamné cet enfant à se faire
piquer les fesses puisque un seul pourra
attraper le pompon et les sept autres
enfants auront donc bon se mobiliser
être incité et ben ils n'arriveront
jamais à attraper l'emploi le pardon le
pompon alors évidemment maintenant dans
cette métaphore je vous invite à
remplacer les mots enfants par le mot
chômeur à remplacer le mot pompon par le
mot emploi sachant que pour actuellement
3 millions de chômeurs de catégories A
il y a seulement 400000 postes vacants
annoncés par la Dares comment ne pas
voir dans cette réforme chômage vous lui
par Monsieur du stop le fait qu'elle
vise surtout à nous piquer les fesses
bon et ben ça c'est du parti pris oui
c'est du parti pris qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez
Marc Lambron je pense aussi
ces temps-ci pour que monsieur du soft
tombe du manège donc le le pompon
politique pour lui s'éloigne un peu
aussi
voilà vous avez regardé un peu le débat
sur les retraites il y a eu l'assurance
chômage dont parle Nicole mais
oui oui j'ai regardé j'ai l'impression
d'être à la Convention en 1793 donc il y
avait un parfum de d'histoire et de et
de véhémence mais en même temps ça peut
dans l'histoire du Parlement quand même
ou pas pour vous non pour moi c'est pas
grave mais on en est pas encore en 1993
où l'anarchiste Edouard Vaillant avait
lancé une marmite pleine de clous dans
l'enceinte du Parlement et je
le prends
blessés au camor on l'a guillotiné
l'année suivante une personne a les
filles pour l'instant et puis bon
j'aimerais bien aussi que reviennent les
duels vous savez que le dernier duel ça
a été en 1967 entre Gaston Defferre qui
avait traité d'abruti un député
gaulliste et il l'a convoqué sur le pré
duel à l'épée on s'arrête au premier
sang comme de faire se marier le
lendemain avec Edmond de Charles roux le
gaulliste voulait l'atteindre dans ses
parties vives voyez ça partait là
finalement c'est au premier sens et
c'est René Ribière qui a été blessé et
le Noël s'est arrêté je vois pas
pourquoi
Monsieur Bompard par exemple sur le pré
non on en est pas encore là bon allez on
va on va terminer avec vous Delphine
tout autre sujet vous étiez à Barcelone
et vous avez rencontré notamment Thierry
Breton et de nombreux de nombreux
investisseurs de la tech Thierry Breton
le commissaire européen qui veut faire
payer les gafams américaines pour
financer nos téléphones oui smartphone
c'est aussi un sujet politique il défend
l'idée que les géants du numérique
doivent contribuer à financer les
infrastructures télécoms en Europe
pourquoi parce que sans son les grands
bénéficiaires plus on est connecté plus
on consomme leur service plus il
s'enrichissent tout ça sans avoir à se
préoccuper de tirer la fibre optique
jusqu'à notre appartement ou encore de
payer des licences 5G à prix d'or et
donc les opérateurs ça ils n'en peuvent
plus cristal et deman qui étaient
également à ce salon international du
mobile a expliqué que enfin la redit
finalement que la situation n'était plus
soutenable les infrastructures en Europe
elle coûte milliards donc ils nous
disent ces opérateurs pourquoi les
Netflix les YouTube finalement ne
mettent pas la main à la poche sans son
les premiers bénéficiaires alors ça fait
quand même des années que les opérateurs
s'époumonent sur cette histoire de faire
payer les bics mais il n'avait encore
jamais été écouté d'une telle façon par
les décideurs politiques puisque
Bruxelles a officiellement lancé une
consultation sur ce sujet du financement
des infrastructures télécomes dans
l'Union européenne ça voilà et encore du
chemin à parcourir ça va pas être simple
pour faire payer les Gafa ça peut être
simple on connaît les puissances des
lobbies bon les big tech évidemment
trouve cette idée exécrable terrible
quand on leur dit qu'il s'enrichissent
sur le dos des opérateurs il rappelle
quand même que les opérateurs eux-mêmes
sont bénéficiaires de cette situation
c'est vrai que on paye nos abonnements
quand même à Orange SFR Free ou Bouygues
et on paye cet abonnement à Internet en
partie pour accéder à ses offres des
services américain 60 + 60 % du trafic
Internet c'est eux quand même donc c'est
ce qui fait qu'on a tous envie d'avoir
Internet sur son mobile son ordi ou sa
télé et puis les Gafa aussi brandissent
le prix que ça risque de nous payer à
nous les consommateurs en particulier si
l'on veut accéder à ses services les
populaires et ce qu'il faudra payer plus
cher et là les associations
d'utilisateurs disent ouh là là
attention nous non plus on n'est pas
très serein avec cette idée de faire
payer les Gafa parce que ça veut dire
que ça pourrait remettre en cause le
principe d'égalité aujourd'hui face à
Internet c'est ce qu'on appelle la
neutralité du net qui fait que vous et
moi quand on se connecte on a accès à
tous les sites les petits les gros sans
différenciation autre que la qualité de
notre réseau et pour penser que ça va
changer est-ce que vous êtes optimiste
ou pas alors on marche quand même sur
des œufs d'ailleurs Thierry Breton le
premier plus que moi il a il a quand
même jugé utile de rappeler que ce cette
neutralité du Net c'était un principe
fondamental dans la législation
européenne donc là c'est compliqué faut
trouver un moyen de financer ces
infrastructures en Europe les opérateurs
mobiles nous disent qu'on peut récupérer
quelques milliards si on taxe c'est big
tech mais on sait que c'est un chemin
donc plein d'embûches pour des raisons
de neutralité du net je vous l'ai dit
mais aussi pour des questions de
régulation de distorsion de la
concurrence en coulisses de toute façon
tout le monde nous dit les prix des
abonnements Internet vont augmenter donc
la question ça va être de combien qui va
payer
pas encore c'est pas vous et que
Véronique je peux plus pas prête à
sauver nos opérations
sont prêts à payer davantage c'est ça
c'est ça le problème on s'arrête là un
mot peut-être une pub sur l'Internet
site de l'Académie française les 9
éditions du Dictionnaire depuis 1694 en
accès gratuit tous ces mots américains
peut vous permettre de revenir au beau
français
merci c'est laquelle musicien qui parle
merci merci à vous trois merci beaucoup
Marc Lambron le monde d'avance est à
lire aux éditions gracias très belle
soirée documentaire avec Jean-Pierre
Gratien demain c'est public c'est moi
qui prend la main sur le débat sur les
retraites en direct de la Haute
Assemblée on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine mardi
[Musique]